welcome everyone uh to the pi
data global 2021
my name is kevin i am
very happy to be here and to be your
host for this session
so now i would like to welcome sivan
bihan
to our session
and she will talk about wounds over time
tracking wound healing via 3d models
very interesting
so steven is a computer vision
researcher and algorithm developer at
health
dot io
where she works on health care related
products
taking them all the way from the
algorithm design stage to a fully
implemented
product with thousands of users across
the world
so
i will despise it to you stephen
thank you very much for being here
thank you
let's talk about windcare
you can all relax all the winds you are
going to see are not real ones
for example the one you can see in the
image is a makeup wind
looks good right
most of the wounds in this presentation
are graphical illustrations of points
why
first for your conveyance but also
because wounds are private health data
and as such we cannot show it publicly
a few minutes about chronic points
before we start chronic wounds defined
in the ones that do not heal within six
weeks
in the u.s alone seven million people
suffer from chronic wounds
the average time that takes to chronic
wound to heal is between 12 to 30 months
and that there is only one wound nurse
for every 500 wound patients
and what about the commentation there is
lack of consistent reporting of wound
management process
so how we as data scientists and
developers can help to improve this
field of chronic points
how can we help the nurses to track the
wound progress over time visually and
easily and by that help them to decide
on the optimal treatment
i am sivan bien and i am a computer
vision and machine learning researcher
and
an algorithm developer
i hold a master degree in computer
science from the weitzman institute of
science
today i am part of a team at healthy io
works on a solution uses the smartphone
camera to create a series of insights
over time
our solution helps clinician to
accurately measure and assess wants and
the navel's meaningful interventions at
the right moments
today i'm going to talk about how we
track the wound healing progress by
building a consistent visual timeline
from different visits of the same wound
before we start let me show you how a
visit in the clinic looks like
the patient comes to the clinic every
week month or more depends on the wound
type and stage
the nurse takes off the dressing assess
the wound status and treat it
accordingly
the visit can be at the clinic or at the
patient house in cases where he's
struggling to arrive to the clinic
in addition to documentation in the
patient's medical file we asked the
nurse to scan the wound using her
smartphone and our dedicated application
in this way we have a visual
documentation of the wound in different
visits and we can use it to
automatically access the wound give
insights and create the timeline
here you can see simulation of the scan
process
let's see an example to a timeline we
have three images from three different
visits of the same wood
you can see that the images are differ
in scale orientation and of course the
wound itself which makes it harder to
compare the wood status between
different visits
so to make it easier we want to
transform the images to be from the same
point of view
as you can see in the illustration here
and this is our timeline after the
transformation when the images are shown
from the same point of view now it is
easier to see the hearing progress no
one gets smaller and better over time
how one can create such a timeline
i guess one will ask why not just to
take images from different visits and
simply align them to each other
it's a very good question but i will
show you why in this case it will not
work
we have two images one from each visit
in order to align images one to another
we first need to detect feature points
in the images you can see them here
marked in green points
the next step is to match the feature
points between the two images
let's go over the different features
that we have for matching
we got feature points on the wound but
the wound changes over time so we will
not be able to make those points to
images from different visits
we can't rely on the wound in order to
do the matching
with that feature points on the
background of the image
but as you can see the background is
different in different vistas one visit
might be at the home of the patient and
the other visit at the clinic
one visit my bedroom one in the clinic
and the other in a different room
and we have some feature points on the
body part
you can see by yourself that this is
very hard to match correctly points on
the skin because it is very hard to
discriminate between them and they have
a similar characteristics
so what can we do
we just saw that aligning directly the
2d images can't work in this case
why not to use 3d models
from this part until the end of this
talk i will describe our process and
pipeline towards a consistent visual
timeline for tracking one healing
products
this is the overall process of creating
a consistent timeline using 3d models
the process consists of three stages and
works under the assumption of rigid body
although the wound and the background is
changing between the visits the overall
body structure stays the same
this way our registration problem and
this entire process does not rely on the
wound but only on the body part
but before we start let's talk about the
inputs to the pipeline the input to our
pipeline is information about your
visits one visit is what we call the
reference statement this is the visit
that we want to align all other visits
into
the other visit is just a new visit of
the patient
for the reference visit we get as input
a reference video consists of a scene
containing the wound
and a reference image from this video
the reference image is the one that all
other images from other visits will be
aligned to
for the new visit we get a video
consists of a scene containing the wound
given the reference frame and the two
videos reference and new visit
our goal is to find a new image from the
new video to add to our timeline
we want to find an image such that when
we align it to the reference image we
will get minimum distortion
let's overview the stages in the process
and then i will elaborate more on each
one
the first stage in the process is
creating 3d model
as we said the background is different
between different visits therefore we
want to create a 3d model a point cloud
with only the body part and without the
background
next aligning the 3d models one to
another
and last go back to the 2d images choose
an image to represent the new visit and
the line to measure the reference frame
let's start
as we just said the first stage is
creating a background free 3d model
how
first extract the frames from the video
then as i mentioned before we want to
build a background free point cloud to
do this we have a body per segmentation
neural network we pass a frame in the
network and using the output
segmentation we filter out the
background from the image
this is done for all the extracted
frames
now all we have left is to build the 3d
model giving the background free to the
images
how we can do that
and it's not the main focus of this talk
i will explain it briefly and in high
level you are more than welcome to read
more about it
in order to create as many model of the
same we need to have several images of
the same from different angles with some
overlap between them
then the first step is to extract
feature points from from each image you
can see here in white
the following step is to match them
between different images each matching
pair of points are now represented in a
different column
so now what happens
each pair of matching points in 2d
should be mapped into the same 3d points
in our reconstructed model
each matching gives us a new equation to
solve
we want to find a mapping between the 2d
point into the 3d space such that each
pair of matching points will be mapped
into the exact same 3d point
now we have two equations given by the
red and green matching points
the blue pair gives us one more equation
and also the yellow pair
at the end of this process after solving
the equations and getting the mapping we
get a 3d model that was built using the
frames extracted from the video
in addition to the model itself we get
camera locations one for each frame
each camera located at the location
where each frame was taken relative to
our 3d model we will see later how we
can use it
the next stage in our process is the
pointload registration
the registration includes all the
transformation needed in order for the
models to sit on top of each other such
transformation can be translation
rotation scale and more
we use prime knowledge that we have
regarding the wounds and the models in
order to relax the registration problem
one of the common techniques of
alignment 3d point cloud is called
iterative closest points or in short icp
it has many variants but i will show you
the basic algorithm
the input to the icp algorithm is two
point drops p and q
this is an iterative algorithm which at
each iteration does the following
for each point in p find the closest
point in q you can use any distance
metric that works for you
then calculate the best transformation
for this correspondence
and last transform p towards q
the icp is a great algorithm but it has
a big disadvantage which is step number
two
in order to converge and to convert to
the correct location the icp algorithm
needs to start from a good initial guess
lucky as we have a prior about the wound
that we can use in order to achieve the
good initial gas
the price that we have or more precisely
we can calculate is the wind
segmentation
using the convolutional neural network
we can get the contour of the wound
boundaries
now we can take the segmentation that
was calculated on a specific image of
course we can do it for each image we
would like
use its corresponding camera that we saw
before and project it into our 3d model
this process of projecting the
segmentation into the 3d model is done
for both the reference visit model and
the new visit model
one transformation that we can achieve
using this segmentation is translation
we can translate the models towards each
other so that the center of the wound
lies at the same point
it's true that the wound changes over
time
but this translation gives us a good
rough estimation for the location of the
wounds relative to each other
in addition to translation we can also
rotate the models along the x y axis
we can calculate the wind surface normal
of each model by approximating the wound
surface using the projected segmentation
then we rotate the models such that the
normalx points to the same
direction great
now we have a good initial guess to
start with the algorithm works and gives
us a good score
but what will happen in this case
both models are telling the like
the icp algorithm will scale them to the
same size in order to match them
we can all see that this is not our
intention because it will scale up the
body part and the wind and will change
the proportions
the icp might get a good matching score
but in reality we know that the results
are on and will give us around
visualization
in some cases like this one we prefer to
get lower score in exchange to better
visual results
we can do it by fixing the model size
and prevent from the icp algorithm to
calculate the scale transformation
what is the scale transformation and how
we can calculate it
transformation is a simple
transformation that increase or decrease
the overall size of the model by
multiplying each vertex coordinates in
the model in a constant
multiplying by a number smaller than one
will shrink the model when number bigger
than one will expand the model
in our case we want the models to be at
the exact same size for example
each toe will be at the exact same size
of the corresponding tool in the other
model
we do it using the conversion stickers
you can see here in the right
orca brass and stickers have they
have the exact same size in the real
world
by using it projecting it to the 3d
models and scaling to be at the exact
same size we can be sure that both
models are on the same proportions
relative to the real world proportions
when we let the icp algorithm to
estimate the scale as part of its
optimization it will result in good
matching score but one visual result
we will not be able to use it in order
to build our timeline the wood size will
not be consistent and stressful
but
if we will calculate the real scale a
priori scale it up or down the models to
match each other and only then we will
use the icp we will be able to get the
results we want
the matches score might be lower but the
registration will be correct and match
the real-world thing the model
represents
the last and most important part in our
pipeline is the 2d image registration
how to choose a representative image
from the new visit video
we have two align point clouds for
simplicity red and blue pointers
we also have a set of camera operations
for each point cloud
and the camera of the reference visit
that corresponds to the reference frame
we will project back the segmentation
from the 3d model into the 2d reference
frame
and into each one of the frames
extracted from the new video each frame
with its corresponding camera
now we have the exact same 3d point
projected into different to the image
what does it give us it gives us
correspondence between points between
the reference frame and each frame from
the new visit video
using this correspondence we are able to
calculate the homography transformation
that relates to those two images
two minutes about tomography homography
transformation relates two images with
planar objects
more mathematically the homography
transformation is represented by a three
by three matrix that can be decomposed
into multiplication of three
transformations the similarity
transformation rotation translation
reflection and scale
the similarity transformation does not
distort the image and therefore not
relevant for us in this case
the afrin transformation that preserves
line and parallelism but not necessarily
distances and angles
this transformation does distort the
image it converts rectangles into
parallelograms
and the projective transformation does
not preserve parallelism
this transformation also distorts the
image it converts rectangles into
trapezoids
our goal is to find an image that will
result in minimum distortion after
applying the homography
therefore we are interested in finding
the homography with the minimum effect
of the affine and projective parts
we have a set of famographies between
the reference frame and each frame i in
the new video as we saw in the previous
slides
and we want to find the item i from this
set which is affine and projective
components are closest to identity
meaning they have the smallest impact
relative to the others in the set
this item i corresponds to the ice
camera in our new visit model which
corresponds to the ice frame in our new
visit video
which is the best image we can choose to
use in our timeline
great
we found we found the best email that we
can
we just found what is the representative
image of the new visit by finding the
homography with the smallest affine and
projective components
all we left to do is to apply the
homography transformation on this image
and get this image aligned to the
reference frame
to summarize all the process we just saw
we have three stages creating a
background three point cloud align the
point clouds one to the other and come
back to the 3d images
use homography to find the best frame
from the new video the one that will
result in minimal image distortion after
applying the
homography we extracted frames from the
videos removed the background created 3d
models align them to each other choose a
new frame and align it to the reference
frame
the proposed application uniquely
combines neural network based image
segmentation an algorithm for 3d pointer
registration to create a unique
visualization for video based medical
imaging
our application will allow clinicians to
visually view the wound healing progress
over time and compare calibrated images
from visit to visits to optimize healing
outcomes for the patient
thank you for listening you can reach me
at my linkedin and my mail and feel free
to visit in my blog and personal website
thank you and have a great day
thank you very much steven um
it was a really interesting application
[Music]
so let's take a couple of
questions i saw one question from
srinivas
from houston texas
so he
says can you
tell us more about the reference
stickers attached to the uh wound please
would you leave the stickers near the
wound or on on the patient for all
visits
no they are one time and at each visit
with the nurse
puts a new stickers because we need to
to take her to
it's supposed to be hygiene so we can
reuse it so at each visit we have a new
stickers to put on the patient around
the wind
i have a question so how
how long is the process
from when you start taking the pictures
to
uh having the 3d model and
and this thing ready like how long is
that process
it depends
on the video on the uh
it depends on the video on the 3d model
it can be from
one minute uh
to a few minutes it depends on many
stuff inside it's like how much time it
takes to build a 3d model
so we have several coaches so some of
them takes a few minutes that some of
them can take really less
so overall i think
a few minutes for now but we are hoping
to get it better in the next version
that's impressive
thank you very much
i'm gonna take another question from
stephen
um
so he
says i am curious about the green
markers that were in some of the images
how are those placed
and
what are they used for
those ones breaks
like what you see here in the right
i guess what if you means what we see
here in the right so we have them only
in the illustration that we made
we have a
3d model body part and we make
illustration in the blender software
so we use it to collect brown truth so
when we align the models one to the
other we will know if it sits exactly on
top of each other
it's not in real scenarios and real
wounds only in our illustration to have
a ground truth to compare
uh have another question here uh
how is the wound healing actually
measured
the size of the wound and
more than that
how do we measure the size of the wound
yes
so we have we have the segmentation on
the 2d image
that we can project it into the 3d model
then we can calculate the area inside
the segmentation in in the 3d space
and using the scale that we just saw
here using the markers we can translate
it into centimeters for this for the
area in the real world
uh also he said my his question was
about
tracking the healing
[Music]
oh
so now
we track the healing visually as you can
see here using the timeline you can see
visually that the wind heals it gets if
it's getting smaller or bigger but we
also in our application we also looks on
the tissue distribution if they are
getting better we are looking over time
on several measurements
when one of them is the
size so we have it visually and in
numbers we really measure the wound size
and we expect it to get smaller over
time so we know it's healing
that's great um
i have another question more in terms of
like
patient adoption and
medical
specialist adoption like how have been
the experience
from
medical doctors and patients that have
already used uh the product
yeah so the product is used already
mostly in the uk
we have it
uh it's only nurses uses it it's not for
the patient itself it's only when he
meets the nurses it is home or at the
clinic
i think it's a great product most of the
nurses loves it it gives them a
documentation and visualization in one
place together that helps them to track
to track the wound visually and in in
measurements and give them the trend
over time of what happens so they don't
need to just look what was the area
before and what is the area now they
have also graph
graphs to help them understand it more
easily and faster
yeah that's interesting if i would be a
patient i would be like wow this is
social cool
yeah some patients are really excited
and we got some feedback from nurses
that the
the fact that they can
show the patients how the wound was
uh
the status of the wound in the previous
visit
comparing to the current visits
sometimes gives them more motivation to
continue to counter the clinic and take
her better of the wound because they can
also see how it progress over time
yeah and in terms of costs
like what can you tell us about that
the patient that it's not for the
patient it's only for the the clinics
the clinics its partnership with the
clinics they can pay about pay on it
it's not for regular use of us
i don't really know how much it costs
for a clinic to use it
okay
right um
that's very
interesting um so thank you very much i
think time is over
if anyone has any other
interesting question please uh feel free
to reach out
um
siban
so uh thank you steven for your talk and
for being part of pi data global 2021
thank you very much my pleasure thank
you bye bye